hey guys said Ford here with AGS news
update that's hot and fresh from GDC
2014 and it looks like a bunch of new
indie titles are inbound for the Xbox
one today's you're in the game
developers conference microsoft
announced no fewer than 25 new indie
games would be making their way to their
new console was also revealed that in
total more than 250 developers have now
received xbox one development kits
through ID at xbox microsoft
self-publishing program for indies to
see the list of 25 in full just head
over to gamespot com however a few
notable highlights include minecraft
meets FPS game gun scape gamespot 9 out
of 10 rated 2d brawler platformer
guacamelee Super Turbo Championship
Edition and ridiculously addictive
two-button fighting game divekick
edition edition plus it's worth noting
the list is quote neither comprehensive
nor chronological and no release dates
have been announced more games are also
in the pipeline and will be announced in
due course the publisher said our goal
has always been to make Xbox one the
best place to play games and that means
having a diverse portfolio for gamers to
choose from Microsoft studio corporate
vice president Phil Spencer said we've
worked closely with independent
developers to bring their own brand of
creativity and innovation to the
platform and today is just the beginning
are you excited to see more indie games
coming to the Xbox one and would this
make you consider purchasing one if you
haven't done so already do let me know
in the comments and for all of your
gaming news just head over to gamespot
com
you